[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était une fois dans un pays lointain
un jeune prince qui vivait dans un
château
quelques mots vous disent peut-être
quelque chose la société de production
Polaris revient dans les Yvelines avec
un tout nouveau spectacle immersif sur
le compte de la Belle et la Bête au
château de Maisons-Laffitte en plus des
décors et des costumes on invite les
spectateurs à se glisser dans les scènes
donc c'est des espaces qui sont parfois
un peu étroits un peu petits on va
passer par des escaliers secrets en
colimaçon des lieux que le public ne
visite habituellement pas c'est un
château qui nous permet vraiment de
faire vivre le compte de la Belle et la
Bête en fait voilà les espaces
s'adaptent très bien à ce compte par
exemple la salle de balle qui est très
très belle avec avec ses lustres etc au
total 500 volontaires et comédiens
professionnels seront présents pour vous
plonger dans un univers féérique pour
rendre la magie possible il y a plus de
six groupes en fait de comédiens d'une
centaine de comédiens qui vont se
relayer du matin jusqu'au soir le
spectacle commence à 9 heures il se
termine à il ne s'arrête jamais
cuisines et je donnerai pas mon rôle
c'est une surprise comme ça ça vous
invite à venir voir le spectacle pour
moi c'est une première j'ai fait un peu
de théâtre et j'aime ça d'ailleurs mais
c'est la première fois que je joue pour
Polaris et je pense pas que ça soit la
dernière je vis un rêve de petite fille
c'est à dire que je vais danser pendant
le bal avec La Belle et la Bête et pour
moi c'est exceptionnel c'est je pense la
seule fois de ma vie où je pourrais
danser dans le château de
Maisons-Laffitte en partenariat avec le
Centre des monuments nationaux le
spectacle aura lieu sur quatre semaines
du 18 novembre au 18 décembre l'occasion
de vérifier si le vécure bien heureux
pour toujours
[Musique]